work work work work work work work work
work work you know Gary player the great
golfer he was a little guy very little
but he worked really hard and he had a
great statement but he'd go the harder I
work the luckier I get and he wins the
US Open you have all these big handsome
guys these big giant guys and they're
hitting the ball a mile and you have
Gary Player and Gary Player would win
the open hid win the Masters hid win
this it went that and he said you know
hey he in the US Open he in a 5-iron to
one foot from the Hall and he ended up
getting a birdie and wins the US Open
right and he came off to clean I I know
I've heard the statement before but I
heard it from him in a meaningful way
they said what do you think Gary what is
it he said all I know is I've been
working very hard and the harder I work
the luckier I get I thought it was an
amazing statement anyway I'm in meetings
a lot my Keller gets very full with
those and then at night after the kids
have gone to bed I'm on email a great
deal I get messages during the day
that's my chance to give long responses
and then over the weekend I send a lot
of mail as well as well I take two weeks
a year to just go off and read and think
where I'm not interrupted by work or
anything else I'm just solidly trying to
think about the future and people get to
send me things to read as part of that
so-called think week so it's nice mix of
things about 25% of the time that I'm
out traveling around meeting with
customers Europe Asia and that sort of
helps me think okay do we have the right
priorities what what are people
responding well to and what would they
they like to see us do better I say to
the my girls all of the time that your
real work is to figure out where your
power base is and to work on the
alignment of your personality your gifts
that you have to give with the real
reason why you're here that's that's the
number one thing you have to do is to
work on yourself and to fill
your self up and keep your cup full keep
yourself full now I used to be afraid of
that I used to be afraid particularly
from people who say L oh she said she
still filled her Sam
she's so good herself and now I embrace
it I considered a compliment that I am
full of myself because you only when
you're full I'm full I'm overflowing my
cup runneth over
I have so much I have so much to offer
and so much to give and I am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it
people just say what they want to say
but I just represent you know being
sucker free and working hard and being
positive
I don't hate on nobody I'm not a
negative individual and I just wake up
and I just go for my and I just try to
work the hardest I could work and I
could have went a lot of different
routes but I just decided to go the
route of hard work the expectation from
where I came from and listen I didn't
come from like the slums and you know
Bangladesh or something so I don't want
to overemphasize it but the expectation
was I would be a cop so I took the
policeman's test and when I was 17 or 18
years old with my little brother Josh he
wound up going into the police and I
wound up going to afford him but at the
time my dad had had his restaurant
repossessed by the federal agents for
not paying his taxes so they came with
shotguns that summer in 1988 and they
close this place down and that was the
most traumatic moment of my life it
probably is the second most traumatic
moment realize after 9/11 and when that
happened that changed everything about
me as a person like to see your dad have
his restaurant taken even guy talking
about it now it's a 42 year old and I
just thought to myself wow you know that
he lost everything and he never
recovered from it that was like the end
of his entrepreneurial career and I said
to myself I'm never gonna fail at
business no matter what it takes I'll
win mm-hmm cuz I'm never gonna what the
feds take my place
and he went $100,000 in debt you know in
tax evasion and all that stuff and it
was very scary but I had no money to go
to college so I had to work three jobs
and go to school at night at Fordham and
I learned to work ethic
that I think made me who I am today like
I'm a very hard worker I'm not the
smartest kid in the class
you know but you know just in terms of
being clever and having hustle I think
my career proves like I'll get it done
no matter what depending on how well you
want to do in particularly if you're
starting a company you need to work
super hard so what is super hard mean
well when my brother and I was starting
out first company instead of getting an
apartment we just rented a small office
and we slept on the couch and we
showered at the YMCA and we're so hot up
we had just one computer so the website
was up during the day and I was coding
at night seven days a week all the time
and I I sort of briefly had a girlfriend
in that period and in order to be with
me she had to sleep in the office so I
work hard like it mean every waking hour
that's that's the the thing I would I
would say if you're particularly if
you're starting a company and I mean if
you do simple math to say like okay if
somebody else is working 50 hours and
you're working 100 you'll get twice as
done as much done in the course of a
year as the other company they always
been focused on work ethic you know I
always been taught there's there's
always going to be something that's
better but there's no reason why
I think that applies not only to sports
but it applies to anything that you're
trying to do you have to work harder
than other people if you want to be the
best and never be satisfied you know I
never satisfy always so I think what I
can do next to be better you want to get
your work ethic so high that people
actually admire you I'm going to ask you
a question right now do people know you
because of your unbelievable work ethic
if you can't answer yes to that man
you're not going to get in that top 10%
you got to get at the top you people
have to know you not because oh he's a
good salesman oh he's a good dish oh
he's an artist so he's a good pianist oh
he's a he writes a great you know story
no did people need to know you for one
major thing first he works he produces
the guys there every day the guys
pushing and shoving because the truth is
no matter how good your ideas are how
good your art is or how good your skill
set is if you're not working man if
you're not vibrating in a frequency that
people say my god how does that guy do
all that if you're not vibrating at that
rate 10x levels massive action
tremendous work ethic that's just a
muscle nowness it's just a discipline in
your life as a way it's a normal way
that other people think is abnormal Ryan
Seacrest Tom Cruise Oprah Steven
Spielberg Donald Trump still pumping and
working as a billionaire look if you're
not working at that level you're not
going to make it get your work ethic in
man it's the American Way work ethic I
think there's no secret to success I
mean I think a B definitely hit the nail
on the head it's it's all about hard
work it's all about going out there and
and practicing more than your opponent
than your teammates it's it's about
mentally preparing every single day it's
about not slacking off putting in that
time and work and you could tell from
Abby that she is put in that work and
that's I think the reason that she is so
so successful but at the end of the day
end of the day there is no there is no
secret to why we are so successful you
have to work I try to do it almost every
day
this is why I'm in
top level many many years I think it's
not it's not by confidence it's a
because I do it extra outside the pitch
when I'm 12 years old
most of the people told me Christian we
are very very good talent player but you
are very skinny very slim and I'd put in
my mind the body we can improve we can
improve you got gym duplication and not
work you can improve so I will improve
myself athleticism means a lot for me I
think the small details in hands gonna
make a huge difference to compare with
with the other players so I think it's
very important to do this kind of work
and I think it's going well on me this
is why I am in good shape
almost all the year and I want to carry
on like that because it's helped me a
lot it's part of me I'm not doing that
kind of work because I have to it's
because it's part of me
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this series let me know
what you think and if we should continue
on in the comments below
and it also love to know which of these
10 lessons rules you liked the most
leave in the comments and I'll join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon